we need a new rule for differentiating
things when their products and let me
explain to you why at the limit when we
think about limits for example of not
just limits but different derivatives in
general if I ask you to differentiate
not just one power of X but like a pair
of them okay so for instance you'd have
to like this just think about with me if
I ask you to differentiate this this is
not a rhetorical question can you
differentiate this for me what happens
to this guy what's that going to turn
into yet the to come out the front
combine to the five so you get ten the
power of X reduces by one which becomes
1 so 10 X good what about the other term
notice 3x squared are you happy with
that does that look okay and sure enough
if you were to graph 5x squared minus X
cubed and then try to expect the
gradient at each point you would see
that this would give you a an accurate
description of what the gradient is all
the pipe so far so good
however you've made a very significant
assumption in doing that the assumption
you've made is that you can just
differentiate one piece at a time right
and then just combine them together in
the way that they were before but this
ends up being a problem if you try it
with products underneath this heading
right this this time consider this now
I'm deliberately choosing an example
that you know what the answer is already
- right you can see what the derivative
of this should be based on rules that
you already know but I want to consider
what happens if you think about it using
the same technique that we just
developed over here right when you
differentiated this this is a difference
right something takeaway something else
it's a difference on where you could say
is the derivative of a difference is the
difference of the two derivatives you
just differentiated them one at a time
and then you just slap the minus sign
between because that's what was there
before well let's have a go at this and
see what happens
what's the derivative of X not a
rhetorical question
just what what's the derivative of this
also 1 and then the original things are
a product so can we say that there's a
product in between there now the reason
why I put this out like I said it
because you know what the answer is if
you were differentiating x squared what
should the answer be should be 2x
because we would follow this right so
this is clearly not going to work for us
it's not true now it doesn't equal 1 it
should be equal to 2x so how do we show
that what you're dealing with a product
you can't just simply differentiate each
of each of the parts of the product and
then go ahead as usual okay so here's
what I want you to do define Y which is
a function of X I'm just trying to make
it really clear by using the function
notation let's define it as a product of
two other functions right U and V each
of which are also functions of X okay so
I'm using function notation here I don't
mean you times X and V times X I mean
you it's a function of X V is a function
of X ok so in other words I'm just going
to write this y equals u times V now
what I have to show you is kind of an
informal proof um it's it's not super
ultra rigorous like a proper university
level mathematician or you know an
actual professional mathematician would
like but it will get across to you the
essence of what's going on and why this
in fact doesn't work it's something more
complicated ok remember we suggested
that dy/dx are just short haired they
just mean change a little bit of Y
change a little bit of X that's all they
be right so here I want you to come over
here and imagine what if we added on a
little change in Y right if we had Y and
then we added on a little change okay if
you've added on a little change to Y
and wire member is made up of U and V
right which have been multiplied then it
stands to reason that over here on the
right hand side there ought to be a
little change in U as well not to
mention a little change in me let me say
that again because this is sort of a
weird idea it looks weird right what I'm
doing is I'm saying okay Y is equal to
UV Y is made up of these two functions
what if we just added a tiny little bit
of a change a small value that's gone up
or gone down if you do it for Y then it
means you should do it for u and V as
well because you would be a sort of like
big components of Y as it were it would
be a little bit like we say okay hey
everyone our class average has gone up
by one your number plus a little bit
what that means is every one of the
little components each of you will also
gone up a little bit you need each of
gone up by one basically okay so that's
all this line is saying a little change
over here should result in little
changes over there
is that okay so far so good alright
let's see what happens if we just expand
this out look the right-hand side looks
like something we could expend right so
I'll just leave this on the left-hand
side it hasn't changed
what is the right-hand side going to
become these are just just terms here
right you can do you know that thing
with your hands that you always do
you're picking up a it turns up okay u
times V is just u v u times DV that's
not a very good V sorry u times DV I'll
just write as u D V D u times V would be
B do you like so and then the last pair
will be in this pair do you DV okay now
again that looks a little bit we're not
used to throwing around these things by
the way to have and then they called
infinitesimal because they're just a
little change any tiny little thing okay
but the the best carries out these are
things that can be operated on just like
everything else
have a look at the lifted my head sides
do you notice you've got a Y here and
you've got a UV over here which we
defined right up here is equal to the
same thing do you agree with that so
therefore these two terms they're really
cancelled they're both the same thing on
both sides so therefore I can just write
this dy is equal to this okay so far so
good
okay now one last step what am I trying
to find well I'm after a derivative
aren't I I want the derivative of Y with
respect to what X because that's the
variable that all of these are functions
on okay so therefore down here I don't
want dy I want give Y or D X so
therefore it's that's the reason I
should just divide everything through by
DX that would get me to the derivative
right so let's go ahead and do that to
buy this divide this to find this divide
this okay there's one last thing to do
remember as according to this spot here
right a derivative is about what happens
when that tiny difference all of these
tiny differences dy du u DV when they
all approach zero right do you agree
with that that's that's what makes these
derivatives the gradient at a point not
just the gradient sort of injured like
on average okay
so therefore if all these differences
are going toward zero
do you agree that these are small these
two here are small but they're sort of
compared one to another so this is just
around these two also small into also
small but look at this guy hmm
remember I was considering things like
this when we were to our horizontal
asymptotes way back when you're graphing
right if I said to you something like
the limit as X approaches infinity of
something like X minus
one over x squared plus three this is
just an example right what's going to
happen to this thing as X gets huge as X
gets enormous what happens to the top X
is getting bigger and bigger and bigger
and bigger so what happens to the top
it's also going to get bigger bigger and
bigger right but do you notice the
bottom is getting bigger and bigger much
faster do you agree right so there's no
matter how big the numerator gets the
denominator will always be bigger so the
desire is always bigger and it's it's a
lot bigger then what will the limit of
this thing approach it's going to
preserve as it's going to approach zero
okay now have a think about that over
here figure out that same principle but
kind of in Reverse okay all these things
are getting small they're all getting
small right but look at this guy right
look at the one at the top here if it's
two things that are getting small
together and they're being multiplied
right so a small thing times another
small thing is going to be an even tiny
thing right does that make sense
it's like you've got both of them
getting four at the same time and you're
multiplying them right so it's almost as
though just like this guy the size is
exaggerated does that make sense
so even though one two three four five
six seven eight nine things they're all
getting smaller
this one gets smaller differently this
one is going to vanish off to zero okay
just like that is going to vanish off to
zero okay so off on the side here you
want to write with me but the limit as X
approaches zero of this particular thing
this particular one more than the others
as X approaches zero this thing is going
to approach zero okay and the principle
is because yet everything is getting
small but look these guys are always
going to get smaller faster than this
guy so the whole thing vanishes away
so that's pretty much it what you've got
left over this side is what we call the
product rule this in fact is the way
it's written on the reference sheet but
it's a bit of a mess written like that
this is one of the early climbs when I
actually prefer this - notation I've
told you before I don't like it because
it's easy to get wrong and all that kind
of thing but it doesn't make this next
line a lot easier to write dy on DX is
equal to now let us swap these two terms
around okay just to make it a little bit
easier to say v times D yuan DX I'm
going to write that using my - notation
as you - see that that's vu - what's
this well this is U times V - my year-11
math teacher said to me oh that's just
called a wolf and it just sounds weird
but it's very raw and it's hard to
forget what you've heard someone call it
a roof this is the product rule this is
the real product rule you can't just
simply differentiate each piece and then
say oh look I've got a number out and
you multiply those that doesn't work